so here's a fun fact for you did you
know that Frieza never actually killed
his soldiers yeah this is one of those
facts that kind of blows my mind as
someone who watched the Dragon Ball
anime first but well yeah Frieza in fact
was not as murderous of a boss in the
actual manga as he was in the anime
adaptation and I mean that go back
through and read the Frieza Arc and you
will find exactly zero instances of
Frieza murking one of his subordinates
out of Rage or whatever the closest we
get is him you know yeeting the Saiyan
home planet but as we all know the Sans
were let's say fired shortly beforehand
so the moral of the story is that I wish
the anime didn't add in Frieza killing
his underlings because when he finally
does SNAP in the manga ooh is it ever a
sight to behold